vont poursuivre 7,8 dans un instant nous
avons parlé consommation avec cette
grande enquête menée par que choisir
autour des centres commerciaux ou
faut-il faire ses courses vous le verrez
dans un instant on poursuit le 7 8 et
cette information qui vient tout juste
d'arriver thibout ruggeri décroche donc
le bocuse d'or devant le danemark et le
japon une compétition qui depuis 1987
réunit tous les deux ans 24 chefs du
monde entier c'est ton illustré lors des
différentes phases des sélections
nationales et le chef adjoint de la
création salé de lenôtre à plaisir dans
les yvelines faisait partie de ces 24
cuisiniers en lice entre hier et
aujourd'hui à lyon et il ramène le
trophée dans l'hexagone depuis 2007 la
france ne s'était pas imposé lors de
cette compétition
la cérémonie de remise des prix là non
c'est tout juste en train de se dérouler
vous aurez dès demain dans notre
prochaine édition la réaction du
français thibault ruggeri vous le voyez
sur les images a commencé à dès 14h très
précisément envoyer ses premiers placé
dès le matin qu'il avait commencé à les
préparer
je vais vous mettre un petit peu
peut-être l'eau à la bouche puisqu'il il
est bientôt 20 heures si vous me suivez
en direct tout d'abord cp assiette deux
poissons un turbo pocher avec une
tartelette de truffes et puis ensuite le
plat de viande le bocuse d'or ce sont de
véritables olympiades de la gastronomie
plusieurs milliers de téléspectateurs
une cérémonie retransmise sur internet
et puis pour les compétiteurs une très
très longue préparation elle a commencé
juste pour cette épreuve dès le mois de
septembre pour thibaut ruggeri à plaisir
c'était dans les cuisines de le nôtre et
nous l'avons suivi je vous rappelle donc
il a décroché ce bocuse d'or
voici les images de sa préparation
reportages de la rédaction
dans les allées de ce magasin simo
ruggieri finalise son menu le mélange
des saveurs et la mise en avant des
aliments reste la priorité du jeune
candidat français aux championnats du
monde des cuisiniers
je suis plutôt minimaliste en fait dans
des associations de saveurs je trouve
que le mérite d'un cuisinier c'est de
partir d'une pomme de terre ou d'une
carotte et d'en faire quelque chose de
bon
sans je suis pas fan des associations
exotiques ou dire on a mis du chocolat
pour mettre du chocolat pour moi ça n'a
pas de sens lors de la finale du bocuse
d'or le jury observera tout à la loupe
du choix des produits au marché aux
gaspillages en cuisine en passant par la
complicité entre thibault ruggieri et
sakho me julie lumeau une fois le caddie
rempli départ pour l'atelier le chef de
l'école lenôtre de plaisir se met pour
la première fois dans les conditions du
concours
au menu de la finale la préparation de
14 assiette de turbo et un grand plat de
boeuf qui doivent rappeler la france le
tout en cinq heures et demie on a
mouillé la chose donc on a un service
traiteur falloir envoyer trente couverts
donc donc dressé dressé au monté en
température
malgré l'agitation qui règne dans
l'atelier
le muguet voix de 30 ans reste
imperturbable c'est quelqu'un qui subit
rarement l'émotion aujourd'hui
automatiquement je le fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de chefs qui va être présents
qui a beaucoup de bruit beaucoup
l'ignorent
c'est un problème timo ruggieri a
découvert la cuisine à l'âge de 11 ans
en inventant comme il l'appelle son
gâteau poubelles à base de cap car celui
qui milite pour une cuisine improvisée
aime prendre des risques et fait revenir
c'est filet de turbot à la poêle
chaque geste est précis étudiés pour que
le plat devienne une oeuvre d'art
et après une heure et demie de travail
le turbo à la grenobloise se révèle être
un feu d'artifice de saveur j'aime bien
la répartition des saveurs j'aime bien
je trouve que les trois on a dû
rassurant on a deux du caramélisées un
peu doué on a du bouillon très léger un
peu boisée avec la cruche ça ça me plaît
beaucoup
rendez-vous le 30 janvier pour la
version finale